est ce qu'on a lu dans le livre de
nelson qu'un maire brésilien voulait
construire un ovni port pour que des
extraterrestres vis garer leurs
vaisseaux oui oui oui oui c'est vrai ça
eh ouais et ouais il ya une ville au
brésil qui a voulu se doter d'un ovni
port bourgenay également un en france
mais c'est peut-être une autre question
je veux pas dire la wii non mais aussi
bien sur 9 ans alors à rien bien entendu
mais s est vraie grande écoute pas et le
mec il a voulu faire un ovni sport
voyage il ya des eaux ni qui vont se
poser tout ça ou est ce que vous y
croyez vous omnisports de blink le voir
une fois une force après les
triangulaires volée et met en colère
volet wii comme ça c'est angulaire volet
triangulaire volée pour quel mariage ce
n'est pas une animation pour cyril
aujourd'hui par drogba jamais arrivé
aujourd'hui il ya plus de 50% de la
population qui y croient dur comme fer
la seule chose que c'est pas entre les
deux soit on y croit soit 60
je pense qu'après avoir lu ce livre il
est évident que j'aurais pas écrit ce
livre si ça avait été pour répondre au
nom bien sûr nous sommes donc vous y
croyez vous allez vous disais vous avez
eu des eaux si ç'avait été pour réponde
oui fin j'ai vu un jeu c'est à lui
qu'est très sérieux que cet
investissement sérieux qui écrit de
façon gai coloré et tout mais j'ai
travaillé qu'un astrophysiciens très
compétent mercuria et je porte mon 10 à
80 à demain demain suffit en fait un
livre dans quête très sérieux avec des
témoignages extraordinaire des
témoignages de pilote de la nasa
maintenant j'ai moins génial russe enfin
je passe je veux pas faire trop long ou
la nouvelle usine à salif keita lille
qui qui démontre en gardant un peu cette
petite part de mystère jade et même dire
cette petite part de poésie qui est
important que ça fait rêver
si le plus grand réalisateur américain
de cinéma a réalisé deux films sur ce
sujet assez qui sait qu'il ya quand même
une raison bergen et voilà merci merci
ils ont été trouvés étaient tous
contents d'eux
oui bah il a disputé hier il n'y croyais
à questions pour un champion mais quel
effet le 4 avril et j'y reviens seconde
à votre question il ya effectivement
rencontre du troisième type c'est donc
le film dont il s'agit bien en compte du
coût de sa vallée rouge de la rencontre
du premier type ses visions rencontres
du second type c'est quand l'objet chose
est en général laisse des traces
j'y viens assez longuement livre oui et
rencontre bien moisi frontenac s'est
donc contacter effectivement je vois que
vous avez lu christine livre contes
accès avec des ce qu'on peut appeler des
extraterrestes moi j'en suis resté à la
rencontre du premier type donc vous vous
avez g oui j'ai vu de l'oisillon très
clair d'un de bain plus que 21 ans
benjamin triangle dindane non non
c'était occurrence un objet
rectangulaire très très lumineux je
dirais environ d'une vingtaine de
secondes que déjà assez long et des
réseaux non aux coupes et sans aucun
bruit et ça c'est un témoignage revient
à chaque fois y compris des pilotes je
vous dis de le pilote de la nasa
sauterez sites antiques et un bruit le
vaisseau oscillé à 45 degrés et s'enfuir
a une voix c'est vraiment géniaux les
garçons venus ils ont survolé un peu non
mais c'est pas moi je vous dis la vérité
moi j'y crois
moi je vous dise est en repérage parce
qu'ils étaient en repérage pour voitures
électriques
non mais vous les faire vivre il voulait
un cas se produisent mais non mr gay non
mais non mais non mais ça va être un
beau succès crois moi j'y crois mais
j'ai jamais rien vu un jour j'ai vu un
objet inconnu moland mondiale inquiète
et c'est la mer qui monte c'est une
babouche la merde c'est que ma mère
quand elle reste de mon bulletin sur la
tête de ma mère vous connaissez les
armes de mer marronne sur la vie de ma
mère quand j'ai reçu mon bulletin mon
frère est long le mesa ba bouche comme à
elle annoncé qu'au match là tu perds à
quoi s'attendre quand on perd il ne
voudra pas vous étiez beaucoup plus doué
que vous dites que vous ne le dirai pas
plus avait il ya un témoignage qui
revient à chaque fois et peut-être parce
que benjamin semble avoir comment dire
ouvert une petite porte toujours vous
n'êtes pas obligés de me croire mais je
sais ce que j'ai fait exactement comme
ça te sont et voilà lui la vue l'ouïe la
vue
il a vu et surtout je sais ce que je
n'ai pas en qu'il a vu
[Rires]
oui alors on m'a demandé mais le plus
sérieux c'est le médecin oui un peu
comme vous j'ai un esprit scientifique
un peu qu'est-ce que vous avez dû
arrêter de dire non je n'ai pas vu mais
pour autant j'y crois parce que c'est
pas parce qu'on ne voit pas que ça
n'existe bien sûr prenez la main de jean
michel maire à première vue elle a l'air
propre et pourtant si vous prenez un
microscope vous rendre compte de tous
les milliers de bactéries kobe avoir sur
ses doigts mais je t'emmerde
[Rires]
ils prenaient vie comme exemple n'ont
pas laissé le médecin qui parle c'est
tabou à l'ebita s'est déjà calé ça c'est
vrai mais c'est vers l'infiniment petit
et youna ce n'est pas parce qu'on n'a
pas les outils actuels pour ne pas le
pour le voir que ça n'existe pas la même
façon que certains de gens peuvent
croire en dieu bas on n'a pas de preuve
qu'il existe plus clair messieurs pas
fait pour ça mais ils peuvent croire à
la victoire du psg en ligue des
champions le problème c'est ça son
problème
oui c'est un problème du médecin les
cherry est ce qu'on a lu dans le livre
que les extraterrestres ou volent
régulièrement la ville de menton pour
rendre hommage aux frais de fred est ce
qu'on a lu que les premiers témoignages
concordants propos d'ovni date de plus
de 200 ans dans le livre au dernier des
frères grimm
les frères si pour l'automne merci je
suis attendu à l'accueil mais non c'est
vrai c'est à mes frais de plus de 200
qui a déjà vu quelque chose
macho et puis il ya quelque chose de
fantastique si vous avez un objet volant
non identifié
non mais je pense qu'il n'était pas de
format il a vu beaucoup de lune beaucoup
lui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'ils aillent mal et ne vous dira un
rôle remarqué pendant cette émission il
embarque à celle chaque fois que jean
michel prend la parole et 10h01 le ben
nelson monfort a fait ça te dis mais
comment développer de telles affiches
elle semble y croire donc sa belle
maison mais qu'ils croient et surtout la
tap moi j'y crois ou veux dire à
l'hadopi de dix ans après à moi alors je
sais que maintenant à nelson monfort
vous me disiez 50% des gens y croient
non mais bien plus un peu plus de 50 %
il ya des sondages évolué 35 ans sont
des gens croient que mu presley n'est
pas mort chez red sonja sohn donc ça
comme pour michael jackson je suis très
étonnant et gêné d'être libre mais ces
sites une croissance par la négative
c'est c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas vu
que ça n'existe pas que ça ne peut pas
exister
merci par exemple exactement ça va des
phénomènes paranormaux mais absolument
rien rien rien à part des gens qui ont
vu parfois délit n'est rien pour le
moment ne peut prouver ne sera cédée
c'est la raison pour laquelle mon cher
mathieu dans le livre vous constaterez
que je ne parle pas de comment dire
d'extraterrestres descendants des ovnis
je ne parle pas du tout de ça je si vous
voulez le fond de ma pensée
oui j'irai exposition jamais sur
matthieu delormeau sur un souvenir du
coup à fond le fondeur prochain j'ai la
conviction et après avoir enquêté
vraiment pendant un an et demi et prier
témoignage très sérieux qu'il ya des
objets qui sont visibles qui ne sont pas
de cette terre de cette galaxie de 2 to
school et qui effectivement lui rendre
visite
je n'ai pas la conviction que ces objets
soit habité je pense qu'ils sont pilotés
à distance partir d intelligence bien
supérieur à l'heure des satellites
autour des mets sucrés je pense qu'ils
sont fils hôtels sont ses chances je ne
sais pas cyril le livre est sérieux je
me remets chasse et non mais c'est vrai
c'est facile de vous dire que j'ai vu
non je n'ai rien vu de l'ordre dans le
livre si on doute on dit voilà je le dis
vous avez on a retrouvé sur plusieurs
kilomètres les débris d'un avion de
chasse qui poursuivent et un ovni dans
le livre extrêmement sérieux oui je vous
lis à vous faire réfléchir lui libre moi
moi depuis que lui livre j'y crois
encore plus dense en rigoler parce qu'il
ya des trucs c'est le but
bah oui est ce qu'on a lu dans le livre
de nelson qu'un homme avait déclaré
avoir été emporté dans un astronef pour
se reproduire
rires avec une alien sexy bonne non j'ai
encore une fois j'ai voulu avec yvan
soit sympathique
donc il ya des témoignages qui ne sont
pas des témoignages sérieux mais oui qui
sont les témoignages amusant donc je
pense ça crédibilise d'autant plus les
lèvera quand les gens me moi je crois à
une vie dans l'univers soul l'univers
est tellement immense que j 3 possession
aux abonnés est ce que met en vente
expérience je ne crois pas aux ovnis
s'il ya des soldes dit qu'ils sont avec
des techniquement très supérieurs à nous
pour qu'il ne se pose pas et viennent
pas nous voir il n'y a pas envie d'être
heureuse et elle apparaît très envie de
manger un grec et je crois que c'est
moctar
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai enlevé sa marque qui a eu
vraiment une expérience qui a vu un ovni
vraiment un truc intéressant donc vient
de vous pousser même si vous parlez avec
des pilotes de ligne de toit
oui mais on les a vues les plus forts
bien sûr vous comme sonia rykiel et je
vous dis jamais bien demain jalouse
développe ce qu'il a à dire que ces
pilotes de ligne vous raconte souvent
qu'ils voient des choses bizarres n'y a
pas de traces sur le radar assure c'est
ça disparaît donc c'est quand même un
phénomène
alors il tranquille a eu un phénomène
qui aveugle à des zones y aller c'est
pas compliqué avoue aussi cinq ans à peu
près en dans la marne en plein été j'ai
vu une forme circulaire passé mais c'est
un frisbee connard enseigner ce qui
était autrefois considérée comme de la
science fiction est finalement un fait
scientifique entre 47 et 69 et us for
skype à 69 s'il vous plaît pas coté à
considérer près de 12000 cas d'objets
volants non identifiés à 37 et en est un
est choisie importante que je développe
dans les jets déclenché une enquête
internationale sur les ovins j'étais à
lisieux j'étais un mariage et nelson en
parle dans son livre
oui pour les mariages à la mode
m'attendais on envoie des seuils des
lanternes thaïlandaises qu'avec une
flamme qui s'envole dans le ciel qui
font pas la truie et que se déplace
qu'en mouvement comme ça sans bruit et
de loi on peut croire s'est dit vraiment
désolé il ya eu 17 et c'était mirka qui
sont venus à l'île d'yeu pour faire le
une enquête internationale
jusqu'à ce qu'il y avait des papiers
partout je sens que je j'avoue j'ai été
voir les gendarmes alors dire que
c'était nous on est désolé où on a
déclenché un fort niveau alors déçu ce
toit celui de nelson monfort gala j'ai
envie de savoir s'il a déjà vu des ovnis
ses doc gynéco un témoignage crédible
doc gynéco alors nelson alors tu vas
pouvoir m'éclairer est ce qu'il ya une
différence entre métaphysique et
paranormal et scientifique
excuse moi c'était normal moi tu
parleras de ça avec mon épouse et mon
chéri oui je crois au sexe est-ce que tu
croises de faire
j'avais un extraterrestre même bien sûr
tu crois aux extraterrestres huawei aux
extraterrestres mais j'ai la preuve que
ça existe sauf que là sauf que les
accords je vois de temps à s'adapter
puisqu'il a la preuve que les
extraterrestres y toi tu as un ami
imaginaire toi je sais tu es un ami
imaginaire
ton ami imaginaire ça serait que moi je
serai pas lui ton ami imaginaire
juste avant est ce qui vous est déjà
arrivé vraiment un truc mais où on vous
vous avez déjà vu oui douvrin -
extraterrestre moi c'est pas il
n'apparaissait pas les apparitions cd
disparition parce que les gens que tu
sois certain surtout qui avec yann
hovine la taille mais ils vont bientôt
sur une bonne affaire que 0 sur une map
à les séparer de ces êtres sur une route
est absolument personne bolomètres
devant 10 km derrière ouais vous voyez
une personne n'a dit pas devant vous ça
vous l'avez vu ça mais oui c'était à
l'époque tout était comestible
chapeautant le signalait m'est arrivé
deux fois et donc mais plus la personne
vous regardez et la personne n'est plus
là et il n'y a absolument aucune
possibilité qu'elle soit partie nulle pa
je sais pas si tu avais regardées par
tous cas il ya déjà de nombreux
témoignages sur des sites isabella
retour sur des disparitions
il ya notamment il ya en corse notamment
yaya il ya des choses qui sont avait en
1957 déjà ça semble ça remonte quand
bien même il est et c'est ce que
d'isabelle est tout à fait exacts mais
vous savez pour pour développer tous les
témoignages qui a il faudrait 10 tome
d'un livre comme celui là bon voila moi
j'espérais faire un livre
voilà et vous vous avez déjà vu des gens
qui marchaient devant vous et qui
disparaissent ttec était plantée debout
d'or amour quoi sur l'autoroute trottier
en train de fumer un petit jouet a fait
rien je n'ai jamais pris de même
n'auriez pas devant lui
je comprends pourquoi il s'est barré le
majorquin alors donc gêné pour vous vous
avez la preuve que les extraterrestres
existent
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
pourquoi ce soir je l' ai amené la
preuve avec moi bah année là cette année
là elle est en coulisse ben asher
chapeau ouais bon chinois en service
doit pas être que l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé brider les
scouts des soucoupes dans le nord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ali bongo ondimba
merci mike betz srinagar et franchement
et nous font une bonne équipe nous
élever son air mutin qui boit que de
l'eau il ya alors il ya un mec qui lui
parlent anglais lui répond rudi rafale
qu'il est en une version voulez vous
asseoir et le soir philippe lassalle n'a
pas reconnu la soirée et ce monsieur là
bas nelson d'ego devant philippe le
jeune benjamin on était moi je le jure
que j'ai par ok pourquoi des jeunes a
menti je vous jure quoi par courrier
chez nous sans notre planète ça c'est
notre anus aulas c'est par ici
il ya 125 ans est rentré par mon anus à
la halle aux toiles et voir reconnue
c'est pas dans le livre sans l'avoir
envoyé sur terre mais reconnaissance
d'accord et la rencontre est un
personnage aussi extra terrestre qu'elle
exécute dans son livre rien candeloro
autres philippe candeloro et doc gynéco
et je t'adore mais merci philippe treil
toi c'est toi
regardez vous le désirez formidable dans
les commentaires avec vous c'est sa
vraie pas tant pour vous c'est un petit
frère c'est vrai que j'aime un des 47
secondes
je vous jure que bonds à la surprise
j'avais été très bien gardé bah oui je
vous promets que les juger par ce bon là
après je les entends d'uld on fera ça
vous l'avez que ce soir sur mes genoux
la risée alésia ses voix